muchos libros de física dicen que la
aceleración dada por la gravedad cerca
de la superficie terrestre se puede
calcular de la siguiente forma es decir
la la magnitud del vector
correspondiente a la aceleración es de
9.81 y aquí déjenme ponerle que en
realidad es una aproximación de 9.81
metros sobre segundo al cuadrado muy
bien ahora lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es es checar si este es el valor
real que se obtiene al utilizar la ley
de la gravitación universal de newton o
hoy bueno y si no lo fuera pues tratar
de discutir qué es lo que está alterando
este cálculo muy bien y también algo que
se me hizo muy interesante es por
ejemplo aquí tenemos la estación
internación la estación espacial
internacional ok y ésta se encuentra a
aproximadamente 400 kilómetros de altura
de la superficie terrestre vamos a ver
si esta magnitud de la
digamos de la aceleración debida a la
gravedad corresponde también a esta
altura a este mismo valor o si al menos
es parecido muy bien entonces lo primero
que tenemos que hacer es acordarnos de
cuánto vale la magnitud de la fuerza de
gravedad
ok entonces tenemos la magnitud de la
fuerza de gravedad que esto es un vector
debe ser igual según las las leyes de la
gravitación universal de newton dejen
hacerlo un poco más a la derecha la
magnitud de esta fuerza la magnitud debe
ser la constante g que multiplica al
producto de las masas de los dos objetos
que están siendo atraídos mutuamente
verdad entonces multiplicamos las masas
de estos dos objetos y dividimos entre
la distancia al cuadrado que hay entre
estos dos objetos muy bien entonces
utilizando esta ley de la gravitación
vamos a tratar de determinar cuánto vale
la aceleración y ver si se aproxima a
este valor ahora tú te estarás
preguntando bueno y como acá
la aceleración si aquí no hay ningún
lado en donde pueda verse la aceleración
pero esto es algo muy sencillo
recordemos por la segunda ley de newton
que la fuerza es igual a la masa por la
aceleración esto que implica que uno
puede uno puede despejar la aceleración
dividiendo entre la masa es decir si yo
tengo la fuerza y divido entre la masa
esto es lo mismo que la aceleración
ahora bien si nosotros consideramos la
magnitud de estas cantidades así es como
lo podemos expresar entonces si aquí
tengo m uno en realidad puedo yo
considerar que esta primera masa es la
masa de la tierra y m2 es la masa del
objeto en particular de la del cual yo
quiero saber cuál es su aceleración
verdad entonces si yo divido la magnitud
de la fuerza entre la masa lo que vamos
a tener es la magnitud de la aceleración
debido a la gravedad muy bien pero si
dividimos entre el entre m2 que sería la
masa del objeto entonces estos se
cancelan y
queda finalmente que la magnitud de la
aceleración debida a la gravedad no es
otra cosa más que la constante g
la constante g que multiplica a la masa
de la tierra la masa de la tierra y
dividimos entre la distancia del centro
de la tierra a la superficie pero
elevado al cuadrado muy bien entonces
estas son cantidades que ya busqué por
ti en internet aquí está la constante de
la gravitación universal aquí está la
masa de la tierra y aquí está el radio
de la tierra muy bien es decir es la
distancia del centro a cualquier punto
digamos sobre la superficie terrestre
muy bien esto es este es esta r que
tenemos aquí muy bien entonces lo único
que tenemos que hacer es sacar la
calculadora y ver si esto coincide muy
bien entonces tendremos primero voy a
multiplicar primero estas cantidades de
hecho antes de eso me gustaría notar que
esto está dado en kilómetros quiere
decir que estos son seis mil trescientos
más bien seis millones 371 mil
metros o lo que es lo mismo vamos a
ponerlo de esta forma 6.371 por 10 a las
6 metros muy bien y con esta cantidad
vamos a poder hacer más fácil las
cuentas entonces voy a multiplicar
primero estas cantidades digamos las
cantidades en decimal y luego hacemos la
multiplicación de las potencias de 10
así que tenemos 6 puntos 6 738
multiplicando a 5.972 2 que multiplica
hace no más bien no multiplica verdad ya
me equivoqué va de nuevo es 6.673 8 que
multiplica 5.972 2 y ahora dividimos
entre c
y punto
371 al cuadrado verdad y esto nos da
punto 9 819 verdad 9 819 5 ok entonces
ahora lo que nos falta es multiplicar
las potencias de 10 y fíjense tenemos 10
a la menos 11 por 10 a la 24 dividiendo
entre el cuadrado del radio que es 10 a
las 6 al cuadrado entonces esto
simplemente lo podemos calcular como 24
menos 11 menos 2 por 6 ok esto es 24
menos 23 y esto es 1 así que simplemente
nos queda multiplicar por 10 ok entonces
solo sería multiplicar por 10 porque
sería multiplicar por 10 a la 1
ahí lo tienen así que si nuestro
resultado anterior lo multiplicamos por
10 nos queda 9.81 95 que aproximadamente
es 9.82 ok entonces esto es
aproximadamente 9.82 metros sobre
segundo al cuadrado entonces tú te
estarás preguntando oye en los libros de
física aparecen 9.81 aquí aparecen 9.82
que es lo que está pasando aquí que no
están siendo exactos las cuentas y en
realidad lo que ocurre es que en
realidad son varias cosas lo primero de
ellos es que la tierra no es una no es
una esfera uniforme no es como que es
una sola capa del mismo material y en
todos lados sino que es tiene muchísimas
capas por ejemplo la superficie la de
las capas interiores de la tierra el
núcleo que no están hechas del mismo
material incluso aquí tenemos agua
tenemos muchas otras cosas entonces de
entrada no es uniforme en sus materiales
tampoco
es que sea una esfera exacta esta es
esta la tierra no es una esfera de hecho
está un poco más apretado por los polos
y un poco más ancho en el ecuador verdad
y además tenemos otro tipo de
perturbaciones menores por ejemplo la
resistencia del aire verdad si uno deja
caer un objeto en la tierra y en
realidad se presenta una resistencia al
aire puede ser a lo mejor no sé si sea
muy grande como para afectar estos
números sustancialmente o no pero bueno
al menos existe de verdad entonces
en realidad esto es este esta ligera
variación se debe esencialmente a esos
tres factores que no es uniforme en sus
materiales que no es una esfera
exactamente y que además puede haber
perturbaciones menores ahora lo que
quiero que hagamos es investigar qué
pasa con la estación espacial
internacional esta estación se encuentra
a 400 kilómetros de altura sobre la
superficie terrestre entonces si
nosotros lo hubiéramos aquí voy a hacer
un dibujo que no es
se encuentra más o menos a esta altura
verdad entonces lo que hay que agregar
es un poco más al radio de donde se está
moviendo
este objeto verdad ya no está en la
superficie está a 400 kilómetros más
quiere decir que el radio de donde se
mueve digamos la estación internación la
estación espacial perdón es de 6 mil 671
kilómetros muy bien esto corresponde en
metros a 6 millones 671 mil metros y que
si lo escribimos en digamos notación
científica esto es 6 puntos 6
ya me equivoqué de verdad en realidad
habría que sumar 400 entonces son 6 mil
771 aquí es un 7
ok entonces ahí es un 7
ok entonces tenemos esta cantidad de
metros y hay que multiplicar por 10 a
las 6 metros así que este va a ser
nuestro nuevo radio y vamos a utilizar
el mismo argumento bueno el mismo método
que hicimos en el caso anterior
multiplicamos ag que son 6 puntos 6 738
que y multiplicamos por 5 puntos 9
722 y dividimos ahora entre 6.771 pero
esto elevado al cuadrado y esto que nos
da 0.86 96 0.86 9
así que recordemos que al multiplicar
las potencias de 10 nos daba 10 a la 1
así que multiplicamos por 10 y esto nos
da 8 puntos 69 aproximadamente entonces
la aceleración que lleva a la estación
internacional es de 8.69 metros sobre
segundo al cuadrado y las unidades están
bien verdad si multiplicamos ag estos si
nos damos cuenta son metros cúbicos /
kilogramo por segundo al cuadrado pero
luego multiplicamos por la masa de la
tierra que es en kilogramos así que
estos se cancelan y luego dividimos
entre el radio al cuadrado que eso está
dado en metros pero al cuadrado sería
metros cuadrados y se cancelan con dos
de estos y sólo nos queda un metro
arriba sobre segundo al cuadrado así que
las unidades están bien y de hecho esta
es la aceleración que lleva a la
estación espacial internacional de hecho
hicimos todo un vídeo de por qué las
cosas flotan en el espacio verdad y no
es que no haya aceleración simplemente
y la estación está experimentando caída
libre pero sin llegar a tocar de nuevo
la superficie de la tierra está
orbitando alrededor de la tierra y de
hecho así es como se justifica que las
cosas no se desploman hacia el centro